so speaking of handling money
david yeah who do you think
is better with money who do you think is
a better investor okay men yeah or women
uh the obvious uh i'm gonna say
women
some kid cause that's the obvious one
you didn't sell me on that one yeah yeah
they didn't come off confident i think i
think yeah
full disclosure your gut's telling you
men though yeah of course okay but i
won't disclosure men have been in the
driving seat of investing historically
men or women better investor
now apparently there's some new
data that has come out
that confirms
research now confirms that women i told
you are better investors i told you this
is a market watch story so fidelity who
i actually
uh invest with or one of the investing
platforms that i use
they did a study of five
million of their customers and their
investing habits in the stock market
over the last 10 years and here's what
they found on average women outperform
men
by 40 basis points which is point four
so for those of you that are not
familiar with what basis points are it's
basically a unit of measurement in
finance and it equals one one hundredths
of a percent so one percent equals a
hundred basis points it's just a fancy
elaborate term of saying percentage you
know because what the percentage you got
to move the decimals over we all get it
so they outperform them by 40 basis
points it's a pretty big deal so here's
what they uncovered about
the women so this is a segment shout out
to the women investors out there okay
shout out to the ladies who run the
world girls
[Laughter]
thank you yeah just let them do it yes
go for it david
so here's what they found out
so they said in addition to investing in
your retirement accounts a lot of people
have that a lot of people have 401ks in
addition to having what is called a
emergency fund we talked about that in
the last episode the importance of
having cash shaved up you know cushion
emergency fund rated day fund they said
then what do you do with the money okay
you've got your 401k your ira you got
your cushion then you got extra savings
what do you do with the money here's
what they found overall two-thirds of
women
are investing their money in addition
to their retirement accounts and
emergency fund crazy numbers for the
ladies and what group of ladies do you
think is leading the way old ladies
middle-aged ladies younger ladies
gen z girls who do you think is
investing the
most which segment of the lady
population in america
c
young ladies
see young ladies would be right the
answer is
female
millennials boom they're crushing it 71
of female millennials that is age 25 to
40 oldest millennial here but not female
for the record
i'm just saying
71 of the females doing that with their
money invest in their money 67 of gen x
which are ages 41 to 56 generally
speaking and then 62 of the baby boomer
ladies age 57 to 75. so
what's the message here the younger you
are
the more knowledge yet we talked about
this all the time finance 50 knowledge
50 behavior right right millennial women
crushing the game crushing the game
and where are they putting this money
one would want to know in addition to
their retirement accounts or saving
saving up cash
63 percent of the poor are putting it
into mutual funds and etfs that's 63 of
the money
50 are putting it in money market and
cds that is low risk that is low risk i
don't even know if that's investing
that's uh better than saving
24 are putting into environmental and
sustainable investments pro environment
and the kicker here 23 putting in crypto
so the women are investing is what i'm
saying here and this is a boom right
since 2018. this is big this is up as
far as the investing goes it's up 50
hell yeah since 2018. ladies are
basically like yeah we were doing good
in 2018. double it up 50 more
we're investing so well since then
investing has become almost like we
talked about uh it's kind of like tinder
it's almost just on your phone it's on
your phone all the cool kids and it does
seem to me
that the reason they're better investors
is because their losses are not as great
because they are not
as gambling as men are
i think men are much more willing to
gamble the money me
right i want to see the mail versus
female chart on who invested in dogecoin
i want to see how many of the people
that lost money in those coin are men
and how many are women those coins shiba
inu all this [ __ ] the casino
whatever like when it comes to gambling
i think it's a man's game and i think
these women are i mean as you can see
here most of these investments that you
talked about they're low-risk
investments wouldn't you say they're not
like throwing their money in like random
individual stocks crypto would be being
the one crypt will be the riskiest yeah
right it's 23 which is here's what i'll
say to that good point because women
it's my thing in relationships
tend to be the more emotional that's
what i was going to say where men you
tend to be more logical and that goes
but when it comes to money women
understanding it's not a get rich quick
game maybe guys y'all got to make that
money bro it's all about the money bro
where women are like i don't know i'm
just i'm just fasting you know so maybe
and you see that in sports too i can
only speak of you know soccer because
that's the one where i kind of follow
both
women sometimes you'll see the national
team for instance colombia the women's
team is sometimes way better than the
men's and because the men's kind of just
sometimes get way too emotional usa
soccer bro the women are the best dude
what the hell is going on there perfect
example why because women are thinking
less emotionally and less
but brute force and more tactically and
there's more
shout out to the ladies out there here's
a couple other stats for you um
they asked the ladies what keeps you up
at night okay other than david
davis yeah
what keeps you up at night 32 percent of
women said not earning enough money so
one out of three women not earning
enough
37 said debt i think we all have to deal
with that i don't think that's just a
lady thing uh 50 worry about their
long-term finances aka while they're
investing the good news is 52
are planning to create a financial plan
for their goals to reach their goals for
this upcoming year so anyway
like marcelo may uh made me point out
this is the women investors are up 50
since 2018. women are investing more
so
again not as emotional with investing as
maybe you know women get the knock for
in real life
the bottom line is
good for you ladies out there you're
crushing it you go girl right this is
where i'm at with this i'm actually
pleasantly surprised
keep it up ladies who run the world
david girls who run the world girls okay
right marcelo your mom i know she's a
gangster in the in the real estate world
yeah you got a lot of respect for your
100 speaking of savage
bougie
no but it's true i think so too and i
also think that um when it comes to them
like setting goals and whatnot i was
thinking about this and i'm thinking
about doing this on stage eventually but
the idea that when your boy like your
homie goes yo dawg i'm about to get in
the gym starting tomorrow i'm gonna get
huge you go
okay
yeah
all right
but when a girl says something like that
they usually follow through like i think
when it comes to following through on
their word i think women are are much
more follow through than guys yeah but
are garbage guys guys are more talk
yeah than women i think women are like
listen i'm gonna invest reasonably you
know what i mean then they actually do
it men are like i'm gonna invest
reasonably then they put 30 000 in
dogecoin and they don't know what
happened so we conclude guys that uh we
are emotional and we don't stick to what
we say with with finances maybe that's
what it is anyway shout out to the
ladies out there if you're a lady
watching the show we are proud of you
keep it up save that money
so you can invest that money say it all
the time
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken